fin des années 60 début des années 70
première alerte sur les dangers de la
pollution la biosphère peut éliminer les
déchets de la nature pas ceux de
l'industrie elle ne peut rien contre les
fumées et produits chimiques les
détergents les insecticides les ordures
l'environnement se dégrade la
consommation de masse se développe il
faut agir un pays prend les devant la
suède le 5 juin 1972 il ya 50 ans elle
organise la première conférence des
nations unies sur l'environnement dans
le décor doré de l'opéra de stockholm
les délégués des 112 pays participant à
la première conférence des nations unies
sur l'environnement ont été accueillis
ce matin par le roi gustave adolphe pour
la première fois les dirigeants mondiaux
s'engage à protéger la planète des
décisions sont prises résumé par
françois de closets le journaliste
scientifique de l'eau et rtf beaucoup de
décisions concrètes de propositions à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
auront été prises elle sut création d'un
fonds spécial sur l'environnement d'un
organisme chargé de ce problème mise en
place d'un réseau mondial de veille de
la pollution moratoire d'une dizaine
d'années sur la pêche à la baleine en
plus des 112 pays de loué nu 250 ong
sont également présentes le secrétariat
de l'onu et le gouvernement suédois ont
pris le parti de laisser tous les
courants s'exprimer ils ont invité des
organisations officieuse associations de
jeunes où plongent scientifique sous
religieux a participé aux travaux car ce
sommet de la terre ce n'est pas
seulement une conférence entre membres
de l'onu c'est aussi le rendez-vous des
défenseurs de l'environnement et tout le
monde peut y participer
tous ceux qui n'ont pas accès aux
bâtiments officiels stockholm a prévu
des forums la possibilité de se réunir
et de tenir des conférences parallèle la
conférence de stockholm se termine le 16
juin 1972
après douze jours de débats à leur
succès ou non pour françois de closets
c'est clairement une réussite il ya
vraiment un effort de synthèse
planétaire ce qui était très ambitieux
mais qui dans l'ensemble a été à peu
près dans la préparation tous à la
mesure de son ambition très rarement on
a vu finalement tous les pays du monde à
bord d un problème aussi nouveau si
rapidement depuis 1972 les dirigeants
mondiaux se rencontrent tous les dix ans
pour parler environnement il eu beaucoup
de réunions beaucoup de blabla aussi
mais peu d'accords contraignants cette
année le sommet de la terre se tient une
nouvelle fois dans la capitale suédoise
cinquante ans après la première
conférence
[Musique]